les négociations sur le nucléaire
iranien reprennent à vienne où les
délégations discuteront notamment de la
levée des sanctions américaines décidé
par donald trump en 2018 un accord
âprement discuté alors que la république
islamique semble vouloir sont à franchir
en annonçant un possible enrichissement
d'uranium à 60%
l'union européenne joue les
intermédiaires dans ces discussions
auxquelles participent la chine la
russie la france l'allemagne et la
grande bretagne
toutes signataires de cet accord appelé
plan d'action global commun si les
etats-unis l'iran semblait encore
braqués sur leur position il ya encore
quelques semaines le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell fait
état de progrès récents dans les
discussions je pense qu'il ya une réelle
bonne volonté au niveau des deux parties
de parvenir à un accord et c'est une
bonne nouvelle
vokoun représentant permanent de la
chine auprès des nations unies espère
quant à lui un tournant décisif
nous constatons que des progrès
importants ont été enregistrés mais nous
constatons également que des différences
majeures subsistent à ce stade critique
les etats unis devraient abolir toutes
leurs sanctions unilatérales contre
l'iran et toute autre partie tierce
avant que l'iran ne mette en oeuvre les
dispositions de l'accord de vienne
du côté de l'iran la publication
d'extraits d'un entretien confidentiel
de mohammad javad tarifs dans la presse
le 25 avril dernier a suscité la
polémique
le ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères y critiquent le rôle dominant
des gardiens de la révolution dans la
politique étrangère du pays le président
iranien hassan rohani estime que cette
fuite visera embrasé les discussions en
autriche
le ministère du renseignement devrait
enquêter pour en trouver les racines
il a été diffusé exactement quand les
pourparlers de vienne étaient
satisfaisants le but est de créer de la
discorde
nous ne pouvons pas résoudre les
problèmes du peuple il y a des
détracteurs ceux contre l'iran et son
peuple
téhéran a évoqué l'éventualité de
conclure un accord provisoire d'ici fin
mai pour gagner du temps en vue d'un
règlement plus durable les grandes
puissances espèrent un dénouement avant
l'élection présidentielle iranienne du
18 juin
faute de quoi les discussions risquent
d'être repoussée à plus tard dans
l'année